thank you morning brew for sponsoring
today's video i'm sure it comes as no
surprise but
like many of you i start my day off with
a hot drink even so
i found i often got bogged down with the
sheer amount of media coming at me
and the feeling that although i was
reading all morning i was missing key
stories so lately i've been grabbing
another pick-me-up around lunchtime that
resets my focus
and allows me to get sped up on the
latest business news morning brew is a
five-minute shot of news items that are
actually fun to read
and are informative for example i got
all the details of elon musk's conflict
of
interest trial in three short paragraphs
how he used tesla to buy a startup
solarcity founded by his cousins and how
he may have to personally cover the 2.6
billion cost
of acquiring that company himself
morningbrew is a us-based service which
means i get my newsletters around midday
here in europe in the past
this was a time of day when i was often
scrolling through news
pretty aimlessly and inevitably found
myself getting distracted by random
social media posts and other apps with
morning brew i get informative and witty
coverage of the news that is most
relevant to me and it doesn't waste my
time even better it's completely free
and takes less than 15 seconds to
subscribe click the link in the
description below to subscribe to
morning brew today
the era of king bibi seems to have
finally come to an end
well that may certainly be saying too
much because with benjamin netanyahu the
architect of modern israel you never
know
netanyahu has been central to everything
in israeli politics and has piloted the
country longer than any other leader he
was prime minister from 1996
to 1999 and then again from 2009 to 2021
not only that bibi as he is
affectionately known also held two of
israel's three most important
ministerial portfolios
foreign affairs between 2002 and 2003
and
finance between 2003 and 2005. in other
words
in one way or another netanyahu has
dominated israeli politics for almost
25 years 25 long years during which the
country has undergone an enormous
transformation
[Music]
we are talking about things as
significant as the economic takeoff that
israel has experienced in
recent decades its increasingly clear
position of technological leadership
on a global scale and its openness to
the world including something that would
have been unthinkable just a decade ago
i am referring of course to the new
diplomatic ties with
major arab powers but as the saying goes
every story
comes to an end in june 2021 the knesset
the israeli parliament replaced king
bibi as prime minister his dismissal led
after an arduous journey to the election
of naftali bennett
as the new leader of the hebrew state
and all of this despite the fact that
bennett's party
yamina barely won seven of the 120
member seats that make up the knesset so
what is behind netanyahu's farewell more
importantly do you want to meet the new
power figure of the middle east
and his more than diverse government
well in this video we give you all the
key details
so let's get started
it turns out that in the elections on
march 23rd 2021 benjamin netanyahu's
party
likud was once again the power that
gained the most votes by far despite
this
king bb did not manage to orchestrate a
parliamentary majority in his favor he
came close but he did not succeed that's
partly because of the accusations that
have brought him before the courts
the fact is that netanyahu is involved
in three legal proceedings
case 1000 case 2000 and case
4000. in the first he is accused of
fraud and breach of trust for allegedly
receiving boxes of cigars and champagne
from businessmen in total the assets are
valued at around
198 000 us dollars then there is case
in which he is accused of negotiating a
deal with the owner of israel's
best-selling newspaper
yiddiyat aharanat for better coverage in
exchange for regulatory benefits for the
media outlet
and finally there is case 4000 in which
netanyahu is accused of granting
regulatory favors to the country's
leading telecommunications company bezek
telecom israel in exchange for positive
coverage on a website controlled by the
former chairman of the telco netanyahu
has therefore been charged with bribery
fraud and breach of trust
[Music]
those are the accusations that are on
the table regardless of whether
netanyahu is guilty or not
what is certain is that this litigation
is something that has eroded
his public image and despite this
according to the polls only 52 percent
of jewish israelis and 56 percent of
arab israelis were eager to see bb leave
power we are not talking about a large
margin and the fact that it was not a
larger percentage
shows us to what extent israeli society
was divided over its historic leader
in any case the division of israeli
politics the enormous parliamentary
fragmentation and netanyahu's inability
to achieve a new parliamentary majority
was a scenario that naftali bennett took
advantage of like no
other to place himself at the helm of
the country although to be fair
it is far from clear how solid his new
government will be
naftali bennett becomes new prime
minister as eight-party alliance
topples benjamin netanyahu skrull and
that explains why a few weeks into his
term of office
the problems began war in the israeli
parliament
naftali bennett loses his first battle
to netanyahu the vote to extend a law
that prevents the granting of israeli
citizenship to palestinians who marry
israelis widens the cracks in the
fragile executive
el mundo but we will talk about all of
this later the fact is that this leader
together with ye lapid of the central
liberal yesh attitude party the party
that received the second highest votes
managed to sell voters above all
on two things first that after four
elections between 2019 and 21
israel has to avoid repeating
parliamentary elections again
at all costs we are talking about four
elections that had an
estimated economic cost of 4.24 billion
us dollars yes
that's right 4.24 billion in uncle sam's
bills
for a country of barely 9 million
inhabitants
the reason for so much electoral
celebration has to do with the fact that
israel
is the only country in the world where
the law obliges elections to be called
if the parliament does not pass a new
budget within a certain period
of time in this case netanyahu's
insufficient majority caused the budgets
to be postponed from 2018 which meant
elections every year elections in israel
have a particularly high cost not only
because of the high security measures
that are deployed to ensure the security
of the elections but also because
election day is considered a holiday for
workers and any work activity has to be
paid as overtime
at 200 percent of the regular salary
[Music]
and of course since netanyahu was not
able to consolidate a clear majority in
the first
second or third or even fourth instance
the message was clear
secondly the parties in opposition to
netanyahu saw in the judicial processes
as a golden opportunity
to get rid of king bibi for this reason
one of the strangest agreements in the
political history of israel was set in
motion
a real mishmash of government made up of
people who would hardly be caught dead
with each other or be trusted to spend
time in the same space without the risk
of ending up in a police station we're
talking about eight parties of all kinds
of ideologies
and with a leader who barely won seven
deputies in the elections but having
said that what is naftali bennett really
like
what could israel's new
commander-in-chief mean for israel and
middle eastern policy well let's take a
look
[Music]
bennett the moderate radical
naphtali bennett keep that name in mind
because it may make a lot of headlines
in the coming months the new israeli
prime minister is
anything but an ordinary politician
[Music]
the son of u.s parents bennett is a
former high-tech entrepreneur who sold
his company
sciota for 145 million dollars
don't think that's all there is to him
bennett who as a young man had served in
the israeli army's special corpse
and despite being a millionaire
participated as a reservist in the
lebanon war in 2006
leading a unit of 67 special corpse
commandos a battle after which bennett
was recruited as chief of staff
by netanyahu himself it was his leap
into our politics
since then and before becoming prime
minister he has held six ministerial
portfolios under netanyahu's governments
among them two of the most important
economy and defense
then in terms of religion he professes
modern orthodox judaism which is a
branch of judaism
somewhat more fundamentalist than that
followed by the current majority
in israel but more secular and
politically and socially moderate
than a heredi or ultra-orthodox
[Music]
and in fact as a side note bennett has
become the first prime minister to wear
a kupah all the time yes you know the
characteristic jewish cap
but beyond personal issues what matters
most to us on visualpolitik
logically the leader's political
positioning and here well
even bennett describes himself as more
to the right of netanyahu both
economically and socially and although
he has moved closer to power in israel
he's become more and more conciliatory
this whole notion of leftists being
traitors and all of this nonsense is
unacceptable what bibi did for ages
the dog whistle against this group or
that group i don't go there i'm more
right-wing than bb but i don't use hate
or polarization as a tool to promote
myself politically naftali bennett the
truth is that the newspaper archives do
not allow us to describe the new israeli
leader as moderate
for example bennett is a staunch
opponent of the idea of two states
palestinian and israeli as a solution to
the arab israeli conflict so much so
that he went so far as to say that it
would be a national security suicide for
israel don't think that he said these
things in a discreet way in a meeting
behind closed doors or
far away from an open microphone no way
he said it in 2014
to significant media outlets such as the
new york times and cnn
the old models of peace between israel
and the palestinians are no longer
relevant
the time has come to rethink the
two-state solution natalie bennett on
the new york times in 2014.
the era of these negotiations is over
the approach that we've been trying for
20 years now clearly has reached its end
naftali bennett on cnn in 2014.
the problem is that by discarding the
two-state solution he is not arguing for
the existence of a single state but
rather he is proposing to maintain
palestine as a kind of protectorate or
permanent colony
protectorate of course subordinated to
israel and that
well many would define that as a form of
apartheid in fact
bennett also defends the military
occupation of the west bank because
he says this territory was won by israel
during the six-day war
of course in no case does he propose to
grant israeli citizenship to the nearly
three million inhabitants of this
territory in the same vein he was
director general of the yesha council an
organization that defends the interests
of israeli settlers in jewish
settlements in the west bank because yes
the new israeli prime minister supports
settlements on palestinian soil but this
is not the only issue where he is
completely frank
[Music]
in 2018 bennett said that if he were
minister of defense he would implement
a shoot to kill policy on the ghansa
border against all those palestinians
who engaged in aggression against
israeli security forces
moreover when asked if this would
include children he answered very
clearly
check it out they are not children they
are terrorists we are fooling ourselves
naftali bennett in 2018. and beyond
whether or not you agree
or whether or not many children are
indeed indoctrinated and trained by
hamas to attack israel these kinds of
messages reveal the new prime minister's
not only hard
but staunchly hard line however
territory and security policy are not
the only items on his agenda
justice bennett is a clear example of a
nationalist politician he is also a
devoted advocate of free markets
low taxes deregulation and the reduction
of union power and privileges
for now in the draft of the state budget
for israel that was agreed on with the
eight-party coalition that has brought
him to power a tax freeze for 2022 was
expressly included
likewise in matters of social rights
despite his status as a modern orthodox
he's relatively open-minded for example
he advocates that lgbt people have the
same rights as any heterosexual person
[Music]
in other words israel has a new prime
minister with a pro-business agenda
experience in private and public
management a long career as an officer
in the army's special corps
including real combat experience and a
strong nationalist emphasis
in short it's as he defined himself
politically we talk about bennett being
to the right of netanyahu
specifically to the nationalist right
but just because he is prime minister
does not mean that he will have free
reign bennett heads one of the most
diverse governments we could imagine a
frankenstein government and why do i say
this
well listen up
a frankenstein government
nationalist rights national liberalism
liberal center
zionist social democrats green left
islamists
eight parties and coalitions that
literally come from all over the
political spectrum this random mix is
what makes up the new israeli government
composed of 28 ministries
a number of ministries that may seem
huge to you until we take into account
that the last netanyahu government have
36.
yes that's israeli politics everyone has
to get their share of the pie in
addition the government will have two
different terms for the first two years
bennett will be the prime minister and
for the remaining two years
yeah lapid of the liberal and secular
centrist yesha tit party will be the
prime minister if they manage to get
that far we're talking about a huge
shambles that was set in motion with a
single objective
to throw king bibi out of power the
question is will this work out well the
truth is that many analysts and experts
in israel and middle eastern politics if
not most
believe that this government won't last
five minutes and that lapid will not
become prime minister at least not with
the current coalition and of course the
very broad and contrary ideological
spectrum of the parties that comprise it
make it very difficult to reach
consensus especially when the going gets
tough
i'm thinking for example of another
escalation of violence with hamas in
gaza without looking too far
in this new government there is an
israeli arab from the
party of islamist ideology as deputy
minister of arab affairs
[Music]
we're talking about mansour abbas it is
difficult to imagine him supporting from
within the government
a military escalation with gaza greater
control in the west bank or a forceful
response in the events that hamas
decides to return to its old ways with
rockets or terrorist attacks but not
only that
among abbas's political objectives
within the israeli government is to
increase
and greatly government spending on arab
towns and villages in israel
something that doesn't seem very
compatible with bennett's advocacy of
jewish settlements in the west bank
in other words the biggest challenge for
the new israeli government above
anything else related to politics
defense or economics is its own
existence to be able to stand on its own
two feet
as much as bennett himself says that he
prefers to put aside differences
our principle is we will sit together
and we will forge forward on what we
agree and there is much to agree upon
transport education and so on and what
separates us we will leave to the side
naftali bennett prime minister of israel
the clashes will come
this government has not been formed here
with a political project but with a
single mission to throw bibi out of
power and to top it off
we're not talking about a coalition with
a very large majority either we're
talking about 61 mps
against 59 who support netanyahu in a
nutshell these are the characteristics
of the new government and the new
commander-in-chief of israel's policy
and defense
on visualpolitik we will follow the
situation closely and we will tell you
all the news
both in new videos and in our exclusive
bulletin for the patreon community to
receive it
you just have to join visualpolitik's
patreon program we'll leave you all the
details in the description
but at this point it's your turn what do
you think of the anti-netanyahu blocks
move to oust bibi from power does this
coalition have a future or will it end
up a chaotic mess
do you think that israel will be in
better hands now that you know the new
prime minister and his new government as
always we'd love to hear your opinion so
do leave your comments below and if you
like this video don't forget to like and
subscribe to the channel best regards
i'll see you next time